est-ce que vous avez remarqué la
particularité des joueurs de rugby leurs
oreilles on appelle ça poétiquement des
oreilles en choufleur le rugby a
l'espiègue l'habitude de taquiner très
fort ce qu'on appelle le pavillon de
l'oreille c'est la partie qu'on voit de
l'extérieur elle est frottée pliée
malaxée elle reçoit des coups se forment
alors des collections de sang ça veut
dire un hématome un notématome même
c'està-d un hématome de l'oreille qui se
forme entre la peau et le cartilage
contrairement à ce que vous faites quand
vous vous cognez un membre il se résorbe
très mal ont tendance à se fibroser voir
se calcifier c'est-à- direire qu'il
reste en place ils durcissent et ça
modifie la forme de l'oreille SS sont
mal ou pas du tout soignés ces hématomes
peuvent entraîner une condrite
c'est-à-dire une inflammation du
cartilage et une péricondrite
c'est-à-dire une inflammation des tissus
qui entourent le cartilage ces hématomes
ont aussi la fâcheuse tendance
d'empêcher le sang d'irriguer
correctement le cartilage qui finit par
mourir donc se déformer ce qui donne cet
aspect caractéristique d'une espèce de
pâtisserie dans laquelle on aurait mis
trop de levure